before we get to today's episode we'd
just like to give a huge shout out to
our sponsor squarespace
millions of years ago this giant sea
scorpion
terrorized the ocean it was the apex
predator of its time
so what if we brought it into the modern
day
and had it fight another giant sea
predator
the killer whale
how with this giant scorpion compare to
a killer whale
would the killer whale's intelligence
factor into the battle
or would the scorpion's deadly claws
give it the edge
this is what if and here's what would
happen if a giant sea scorpion
fought a killer whale the killer whale
or
orca is one of the modern sea's
deadliest creatures
weighing in at 5500 kilograms and
10 meters in length this mammal can take
on
almost anything in the ocean but
don't count out the giant scorpion just
yet after all
the killer whale has never faced
something like this before
it's the largest scorpion ever and
is bigger than humans at two and a half
meters in length
and the killer whale better watch out
for the scorpion's
incredibly powerful claws
now let's begin the fight
the killer whale would start the battle
off its game
that's because these creatures are used
to hunting in packs and
ganging up on their prey but it
eventually gains its bearing and
it's now ready to take on the scorpion
since the
orca is much bigger than the giant sea
scorpion
it looks like it's trying its best to
avoid the orca as much as possible
unfortunately that doesn't work for long
since the killer whale uses
echolocation to understand its
surroundings
this makes it virtually impossible for
the sea scorpion to avoid the killer
whale much longer
the orca searches around using its echo
location and
eventually spots the sea scorpion now
the killer whale is approaching the
scorpion at 55 kilometers per hour
the orca approaches his opponent and is
violently jabbed at and sliced by the
scorpion's claws
since the sea scorpion wasn't a very
smart creature back in its day
it doesn't know where to attack this
massive beast
and because of that the killer whale
only gets a couple of scratches
but now instead of continuing to fight
the whale goes up for
air
[Music]
now the killer whale and the sea
scorpion are going to rest up for a bit
while i talk to you about this
episode's sponsor squarespace
squarespace is the ultimate
all-in-one tool to build the perfect
website seriously
if you want to start a business build a
portfolio or share your music
now is the time to do it and what better
way to do it than with squarespace
you can customize your site whatever way
you like with their stunning templates
and
easy to use tools squarespace makes it
incredibly simple to import video and
audio and
add social media integrations with just
a few clicks
so if you need a home for all your
creative projects and ideas
head over to squarespace.com for a free
trial
and when you're ready to launch your
site go to squarespace.comwhatif
to save 10 off your first purchase of a
website or domain
alright now let's start round two
after the killer whale has gotten some
air it comes back down for round two
and it looks like the scorpion has
hidden once again but
that won't stop the orca it quickly uses
its echolocation to spot the scorpion
and approaches its opponent once again
since the orca is so well known for
using its brain
rather than its brute strength for
hunting we know it's learned from its
previous battle with the sea scorpion
the whale doesn't hesitate and instantly
bites the scorpion's arms
after wrestling with it for a short time
the whale's deadly jaws managed to snap
off the scorpion's arm now the scorpion
is severely battered and bruised it
attempts to attack with its good arm but
the whale smashes it down with its fin
and goes in for the final blow
so although this giant scorpion
dominated the ocean
millions of years ago it looks like our
modern day apex predator
is the ultimate victor i wonder how this
whale would fare against
a megalodon shark if it were living in
the modern day
well we'll leave that story for another
what if
you